A route hijack is an attack on origin
authentication because in a, in a route hijack,
the AS that is advertising the prefix is
actually not the rightful owner of that prefix. In
addition to control plan security, we also have
to worry about data plan security or determining
whether data is traveling to the intended locations.
In general, it can be extremely hard to verify
that packets or traffic is traveling
along the intended route to the destination.
Or that it, in fact, even reaches the intended destination in the first place.
Guaranteeing that traffic actually traverses the advertised
route remains an important open problem in
internet security. So how do these attacks on routing happen in the first place?